Криємо! Пішли!
Вперед! Крию!
Так відбувається наступ підрозділу ЗСУ за технікою "каскад".
Втім тут не чути звуків артилерії і не видно російських угрупувань, бо це не фронт, а тренування.
За технікою українців спостерігає Майкл - керівник групи іноземних військових інструкторів, що навчають такі підрозділи.
За одне заняття відпрацьовують одразу кілька вправ.
Зараз хлопці практикують техніку взяття ворожого бійця в полон.
Це стандарт, коли один затримує, а інший контролює.
Кожен солдат має вміти робити це безпечно для себе і побратимів.
Після інструктажу колег Майкла українці кілька разів практикують міжнародні військові тактики,
в тому числі армій НАТО, за ролями і з чітким сценарієм.
Кожного разу є над чим працювати.
Буду проводити обшук, є спеціальний протокол, за яким треба від "А" до "Я" пройти.
Ніхто мене ще не бачить. В ролі терориста проводжу розвідку.
Зараз я ще сам не знаю, що зі мною станеться.
Прибрав зброю! На живіт ліг!
З якого підрозділу?
- "Вагнер".
Опустити ноги! Яка була задача на цьому об’єкті?
- Розвідка. - Це деенерівець!
Ми робимо максимально наближено до бойових дій, ми ставимо розтяжки, використовуємо дрони, евакуації.
Інструктор одразу заробив наш авторитет, він побував у багатьох гарячих точках.
Багато інструкторів з Америки, Європи. Більшість пройшли війну в Іраку, Афганістані.
Про свій бекграунд і досвід інструктори говорять обережно.
Більшість - колишні військові НАТО, спецпризначенці штурмових підрозділів SWAT
або поліції США чи європейських країн.
Керівник групи Майкл ховає обличчя, а його команда взагалі не може давати інтерв’ю на камеру -
у цілях їхньої безпеки.
Ми не можемо обговорювати наші біографії.
Рішення лишитися анонімними було прийнято, тому що подібні навчання зазвичай проводяться на рівні держав, за рішенням уряду.
Ми тут виключно як ентузіасти, які добровільно ризикують собою,
аби допомогти українцям своїм досвідом підвищити шанси вижити на війні.
Втім, у такому разі ми і наша локація - це ціль для ворога.
Однак Майкл геть не приховує мотивації, через яку він особисто приїхав сюди з Нью-Йорка,
а його колеги - з різних країн світу.
Коли я вперше приїхав у березні, я привіз як волонтер гуманітарну допомогу
і допомагав військовим з евакуацією цивільних.
Тоді я зрозумів, що можу бути корисним і для самих військових,
аби допомогти готувати їх до бою, аби Україна перемогла.
Тож, я зв’язався з людьми, з якими колись працював у цій сфері в минулому,
і ми почали наші тренування - з членами територіальної оборони, а вже пізніше - з військовими ЗСУ.
Кожен з нашої команди має свою спеціалізацію,
глибоко володіє відповідними навичками і знаннями.
І ми готові ними ділитися.
Тренування тривають щодня по 6 годин.
Інструктори вчать техніці бою, як проводити розвідку, патрулювання,
евакуацію та надавати першу медичну допомогу пораненим побратимам.
Коли підрозділ проходить курс з кількох занять, інструктори беруться за нову групу військовослужбовців.
Загалом повний вишкіл у команди Майкла пройшли 600 українських захисників.
Інтерв’ю для медіа - це шанс розповісти про цю ініціативу
і залучити до наших тренувань якомога більшу кількість українських військових.
Зараз популярний меседж про те, що Україні потрібно більше зброї.
Так, це важливо, але якщо ви запитаєте бійця, що б він вибрав: зброю чи тренування, він відповість "тренування".
Україна мусить мати добре підготовлених бійців.
Втім, за кілька місяців тренувань Майкл збагнув, яка нестача амуніції є в ЗСУ.
Тож додатково почав організовувати не лише навчання,
а і доставку обладнання для військових від європейських благодійних фондів.
Ми домовилися про підтримку для хлопців із литовською благодійною організацією.
Ось нещодавно вони надіслали цьому підрозділу кілька таких "пташок".
Ми організовуємо усе вчасно, аби у підрозділу був час навчитися це використовувати до виїзду на фронт.
Усе, чого навчили інструктори, вже стало в нагоді на полі бою,
розповідає український захисник із позивним "Казах".
Тепер він разом зі своїм підрозділом проходить курс вдруге.
Розповіли, як правильно робити евакуацію, як треба підготувати до евакуації.
Мої побратими виносили "трьохсотих", поранених, які підірвались на розтяжці МОН-80.
Якби ми не тренувались, не знали, як це робити, то "300" стали б "200".
Кожного разу це треба повторювати і повторювати, тому що багато ніколи не буде.
Ми не знали багато таких маленьких нюансів.
Моральна підтримка. Вони нам не дають опускати голову, щоб не впадати в емоційну яму.
Це Завтра, це ім’я кішки. Ми зустріли її тут у лісі під час першого тренування, вона була холодна і голодна.
Тепер приходить щодня. Вона стала нашим другом і антистресом, дуже ніжиться, така мила.
"Абрамси", "Леопарди" - це добре. Але про таких, як кішка Завтра або старенька бабуся
у зруйнованому будинку в Донецьку, може потурбуватися лише жива людина.
Піднімати український прапор на звільнених територіях будуть українські воїни.
Нам потрібні професіонали, які повернуться додому живими.
За словами Майкла, його команді морально важко бути далеко від власного дому,
але особисто він повертатися до Нью-Йорка не думає, доки Україна не переможе.